[Musik]
mehr freiheiten für geimpfte
gesundheitsminister sparen stellt
menschen die beide impfdosen erhalten
haben erleichterungen in aussicht
ostern ohne pilger papst franziskus
spendet den segen urbi et orbi von nur
wenigen gläubigen und einfach mal raus
während im süden die oster sonne lockt
bleiben im norden bei trüben wetter die
strände leer
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und ein herzliches
willkommen an diesem ostersonntag wo die
zahl ist auch dabei für den sport sehr
gerne guten abend kann jemand der gegen
korona geimpft ist das virus weiter
übertragen nach wie vor ist das nicht
komplett auszuschließen aber so heißt es
in einem neuen bericht des robert koch
instituts das risiko ist ausgesprochen
gering
der gesundheitsminister will deshalb
zweifach geimpften nun doch sonderrechte
gewerbe im moment würden davon etwas
mehr als vier millionen menschen
profitieren das sind gut fünf prozent
der bevölkerung gut 12 prozent haben
bisher mindestens eine impfdosis
erhalten
im schnitt werden im moment pro tag etwa
270.000 menschen geimpft das sollen im
laufe des monats vielmehr werden sobald
mehr impfstoff zur verfügung steht
über mögliche freiheiten für geimpfte
thomas garcia impfzentrum dresden die
dosis sozusagen ein ostergeschenk wenn
es gibt hoffnung auf mehr freiheiten
jedenfalls für die die zum zweiten mal
ihren tipps bekommen
der bundesgesundheitsminister sagt wer
vollständig geimpft ist kann in zukunft
wie jemand behandelt werden der negativ
getestet ist würde bedeuten ohne test
etwa ins geschäft und nach
auslandsreisen keine quarantäne pflicht
all das wenn nach der zweiten impfung 14
tage vergangen sind grundlage für den
vorstoss erkenntnisse des rk ii
das zweifach geimpfte andere menschen
anstecken das risiko ist minimal gut
abgesichert ist und das zeigt sich jetzt
im moment auch relativ deutlich dann
sind solche zusätzlichen freiheiten
vergifte richtig wie beispielsweise
friseurbesuche oder auch also das sitzen
auf terrassen vor den restaurants das
wird auf jeden fall auch wieder gehen
aber ist das gerecht nein sagt die afd
sie spricht von einer impfpflicht durch
die hintertür und von einem spaltpilz
meinungen ich fände es jetzt unfair wenn
ich jetzt andere freiheiten hätte als
jemand der nicht geimpft ist wenn alle
die chance gehabt haben
ging es darum zu können dann kann man
darüber reden ich finde es zum beispiel
ganz schlimm dass die alten leute jetzt
noch trotzdem sie geimpft sind in den
heimen überhaupt keine verbesserungen
haben verbesserungen erleichterungen
noch ist nichts beschlossen virologen
sagen zu den freiheiten sind kein
freibrief
da habe ich jetzt einen negativen
antigen schnelltest habe oder zweifach
erfolgreich geimpft bin sollte ich mich
weiterhin konsequent an die
abstandsregeln hygieneregeln maske
tragen regeln halten
deutschland wartet hofft auch auf mehr
freiheit für einige war das heute also
eine frohe botschaft zu ostern eine art
im turbo ist seit heute im saarland in
betrieb das bundesweit erste impfzentrum
der bundeswehr
das besondere die soldaten impfen dort
rund um die uhr zur premiere kam auch
die chefin
außer brücken susanne freitag an diesem
ostersonntag ist
bundesverteidigungsministerium annegret
kramp karrenbauer in ihrer
saarländischen heimat beruflich
truppenbesuch im impfzentrum auf dem
kasernengelände impfen soldaten ab heute
rund um die uhr
seit freitag konnten im kandidaten sich
anmelden 15.000 nach termine waren
sofort vergeben und bei der bundeswehr
geht noch mehr können bis zu 28
bundeswehr eigene impfzentren
aufrechterhalten auch mit 24 7
das angebot steht an andere bundesländer
an städte und gemeinden im marathon
das passt zum saarland modell von
ministerpräsident tobias hat ab dienstag
soll mehr öffnen mit verpflichtenden
tests mitten in der dritten welle hatte
er dafür viel kritik bekommen
trotzdem will er den systemwechsel es
ist im mpk beschluss festgehalten dass
wir eben wenn inzidenz instabil sind
auch bereich eröffnen können wir die
außengastronomie
wir halten uns an diesen beschluss und
wollen mit diesen modellhaften vorhaben
hier an der saar auch dazu beitragen
dass wir es schaffen deutschlandweit
auch andere möglichkeiten mildere mittel
auszuloten
doch einige die öffnen sollen sind
skeptisch die werte steigen auch im
saarland das risiko erheblich wird auch
am dienstag treffen sich nicht offen
machen weil der ganze apparat muss
hochgefahren werde ich muss meine
mitarbeiter aus der kurzarbeit nehmen
ist schon ein riesiger aufwand bei allem
willen zu mehr normalität bleibt das
virus ein unberechenbarer gegner
die bundesregierung erklärt ein
nachbarland nach dem anderen zum hoch
inzidenz gebiet nach tschechien polen
und frankreich gilt das wegen der hohen
infektionszahlen ab dienstag auch für
die niederlande
wer von dort nach deutschland einreist
braucht einen negativen test darüber
hinaus gilt eine quarantäne pflicht für
pendler gibt es ausnahmen
der blick auf die korona zahlen an
diesem ostersonntag wegen der feiertage
sind sie allerdings weniger
aussagekräftig die gesundheitsämter
haben dem robert-koch-institut 12.000
196 corona neuinfektionen gemeldet das
sind 5000 20 weniger als vor einer woche
zudem wurden 68 neue todesfälle
verzeichnet die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents sinkt auf 127 heftige kritik
gibt es nach der ausufernden demo der
sogenannten querdenker in stuttgart und
zwar an polizei und stadt rund 15.000
menschen hatten gestern gegen die korona
politik protestiert größtenteils ohne
masken und abstand ohne dass die polizei
eingeschritten wäre
vereinzelt kam es zu übergriffen auf
journalisten die polizeigewerkschaft
warf der stadt vor dass sie die
kundgebung überhaupt erlaubt hat mobile
wahlurnen mit teams in schutzkleidung
dass es nur eine besonderheit der
parlamentswahl heute in bulgarien die
dritte corona welle hat das ärmste land
der eu voll erwischt
ihr corona krisen management und
korruptionsskandale haben der regierung
in verruf gebracht die wahl gilt daher
als abstimmung über ministerpräsident
borissov und seine europafreundliche
partei wolf christian ullrich berichtet
in bulgarischen krankenhäusern heute
extra wahlkabinen damit auch corona
kranke stimme abgeben können blickt
trotz seiner krankheit werde er wählen
sagt einer
für jobs und ein besseres leben wenn
wegen corona am ende doch weniger leute
wählen könnte das dem amtsinhaber nützen
ministerpräsident borissov der die
presse heute aussperrte als er seine
stimme abgab
kein zufall seine regierung ist stark
umstritten
tausende hatten im vergangenen jahr
monatelang protestiert gegen die
schwache justiz gegen die korruption und
gegen die skandale der regierung
so hatte ein vize minister sein
ferienhaus mit eu mitteln saniert und
eine ministerin empfahl über betrug mit
eu mitteln wie bett zu steigen sonst so
wirklich streicht uns die eu womöglich
auf das geld bulgarien ist das ärmste
land in der eu
vor allem die jungen leute beklagen dass
die korruption die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung behindert korruption ist in
bulgarien die norm geworden
sie hat ein solches netzwerk gebildet
das sich von einem gefangenen
staatsstreich armut korruption und der
kampf gegen das corona virus viel zu tun
für eine neue regierung in bulgarien mit
bis zu sieben parteien im parlament
könnte die regierungsbildung jedoch
schwierig werden
ostersonntag im schatten von corona das
heißt auch zum zweiten mal blieb der
petersplatz in rom menschenleer und der
papst musste die ostermesse mit ganz
wenigen im petersdom feiern
franziskus fordert eine gerechte
verteilung der impfstoffe und er predigt
die osterbotschaft gebe hoffnung trotz
der weltweiten pandemie ausruhen andreas
postel
zur ostermesse im petersdom spricht
papst franziskus von der hoffnung die
für die christenheit mit der
auferstehung verbunden ist besonders in
dieser corona pandemie in der vor allem
die ärmsten der welt hilfe benötigen
beim impfen fordert der pontifex in
seiner predigt eine gerechte verteilung
[Musik]
im sinne eines internationalismus der
impfstoffe fordere ich daher die gesamte
internationale gemeinschaft auf in
gemeinsamer anstrengungen die
verzögerungen bei der
impfstoffversorgung zu überwinden und
eine solidarische verteilung speziell
mit den ärmsten ländern zu fördern
der 84 jährige warnt vor der
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen krise und
ruft dazu auf kriegerische konflikte und
neue militärische aufrüstung weltweit zu
beenden wegen des corona schutzes dürfen
nur etwa 200 würdenträger und zuhörer an
der ostersonntags messe teilnehmen
draußen auf dem petersplatz fehlen wie
bereits im vorjahr die zehntausende
pilger wie es ostern aus aller welt nach
rom zieht sie verfolgen den
traditionellen papst segen auch ostern
2021 aus der ferne
es fehlt ein geschenk das bewusst man
handle so wie et orbi der stadt und dem
erdkreis
was tun an den feiertagen wenn so vieles
wegen corona problematisch es im vorteil
sind eindeutig all jene die schönes
wetter haben dann ist zumindest mal
eiersuchen draußen möglich deutlich
frustrieren da wird es wenn das wetter
nicht mitspielt klassen hat mehr
hauptsache nach draußen das war für
viele an diesem osterwochenende das
motto doch nicht alle hatten damit glück
die legendäre bisky meile auf sylt heute
mittag immerhin der osterhase ist zum
traditionellen eierlauf gekommen sonst
kaum jemand vom erwarteten großen run
der ferienwohnungsbesitzer und
tagesgäste blieb bei eisigen wetter
wenig übrig die zahl der neuinfektionen
ist mit 22,4 pro 100.000 einwohnern im
kreis nordfriesland vergleichsweise
niedrig die hoffnung ist so zur
modellregion für öffnungen zu werden wir
müssen die regeln natürlich auch
akzeptieren wir werden auch diese
modellregion geschichte nur mitmachen
wenn wir ganz strikte und feste
spielregeln haben sonst ist auch uns das
risiko einfach zu groß
nahezu verwaist heute vormittag aber
noch der strand in westerland zu eisig
zu windig strahlender sonnenschein zog
dagegen viele münchner ins freie
vor allem natürlich an die isar
schwierige zeit aber wir versuchen das
beste bei den herrlichen sonnenschein zu
machen also wir haben eine große familie
die vermissen wir natürlich aber wir
halten uns an die kontakt beschränkungen
ostern in der pandemie 2021 das nord süd
gefälle beim wetter wird aber bald
vorbei sein
nächste woche gibt es das sylter wetter
fast überall was ich so drüber mit sport
ja die fußballerinnen des vfl wolfsburg
haben das finale im dfb pokalwettbewerb
erreicht die mannschaft setzte sich im
zweiten halbfinale gegen bayern münchen
mit 2 0 durch für die bayern ist es die
erste niederlage nach 26
pflichtspielsiegen wolfsburg beginnt
stark und trifft früh alexandra popp zum
1 0 nach 13 minuten sechs jahre
nacheinander waren sie pokalsiegerinnen
das ist in dieser saison noch das
einzige realistische titel ziel in der
nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte macht
eva paar das zwei zu null
auch nach der pause bayern zu harmlos
simone laudehr und lehrer schüler
vergeben beste chancen in der hektischen
schlussphase muss nationalspielerin pop
verletzt aufgeben bei bayern sieht
prozessoren sind nach einer notbremse
rot es bleibt beim 2 0 wolfsburg spielt
im finale am 30 mai gegen eintracht
frankfurt und in der fußball bundesliga
der männer hat der vfb stuttgart im
ersten sonntagsspiel gegen werder bremen
mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen
den treffer erzielte der bremer ludwig
augustin zum mit einem eigentor der
ruder-achter der universität cambridge
hat das boat race gegen den ewigen
rivalen oxford gewonnen normalerweise
verfolgung bis zu einer viertelmillion
menschen das traditionsreiche rennen am
ufer der themse wegen der korona
pandemie musste es diesmal außerhalb
londons stattfinden
ziemlich gerade und menschenleer die 192
sste auflage des boat race eine
historische zum ersten mal mit einer
schiedsrichterin und erstmals ohne
zuschauer
die ruderer aus cambridge im hintergrund
mit den besseren start
die light blues hellblauen sollten ihren
baldigen vorsprung bis ins fünf
kilometer entfernte ziel bringen der 85
sieg für cambridge im 166 zu helfen
verdienter lohn ein gemeinsames park mit
den ebenfalls siegreichen frauen ihrer
uni
sehr frisch auf gott das war's die
wettervorhersage für ostermontag sie
ahnen es würde ich ihnen am liebsten
ersparen von norden her regen später
übergang zu wechselnder bewölkung mit
schnee- und graupelschauern sowie kurzen
gewittern
im süden noch länger freundlich starker
westlicher wind mit schweren sturmböen
höchstwerte vier bis 14 grad
in den nächsten tagen sehr wechselhaft
mit etwas sonne und viel schnee graupel
und regenschauern
christian sievers begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute-journal hier übernimmt
morgen petra gerster das gesamte heute
team wünscht ihnen frohe ostern und
einen schönen abend noch auf wiedersehen